hey 42 here as you're probably aware i'm
a citizen of great britain a place known
for umbrellas and warm beer tea and the
queen
pork sausages and big ben there are many
things that epitomize the identity of
the uk but few more so than the annual
wimbledon tennis tournament
founded in 1877 wimbledon is the very
definition of british style and grace
fink champagne and strawberries
perfectly manicured lawns and sports
stars playing with hairy balls
but it wasn't always quite so genteel in
fact in the earliest days of the
tournament one of wimbledon's biggest
stars was a career con artist crook and
violent murderer whose story starts on
center court and ends in criminal court
so if you have the appetite for the
underbelly of upper-class british
society sit yourself down and prepare
for the story of via st legere gold
the wimbledon finalist with a killer
backhand
no i've had people close to me start to
lose their hair as early as their
twenties and it's always been an
upsetting experience
if you're in the same boat then you're
not alone did you know two out of three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
but the best thing you can do to prevent
hair loss is take the initiative now and
do something about it whilst you've
still got hair left i really like keeps
because it makes treatment super easy by
delivering your hair loss medication
every three months so you can say
goodbye to awkward doctor visits or
waiting in pharmacy checkout lines
there's a good reason that keeps has
more five star reviews than any of its
competitors and hundreds of thousands of
men trusts them for their hair loss
prevention medication if you're like me
you're probably not ready to lose your
hair just yet but prevention is key the
faster you act the faster you'll see
results and the sooner you start using
keeps the more hair you'll save
so if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it for a
limited time go to keeps.com
42 or click the link in the description
below to receive 50 off your first order
thanks to keeps for sponsoring this
video
the year was 1879 and the wimbledon
tennis championship was hosting the
third final in its young history the men
competing for the title of tournament
champion were reverend john hartley from
yorkshire and via st legere gold an
opponent the good reverend described as
a cheery and wild irishman
wild for sure because the man from the
land of the shamrock was later
responsible for what would become known
as the monte carlo trunk murder
via st legere gold as you can probably
deduce from his name was born into a
rich irish aristocratic family on the
2nd of october 1853. the young man
showed a flare for athletic pursuits
including boxing but in the 1870s gold
the grandson of a baronet swapped body
shots for cross-court shots as the game
of lawn tennis took the english nobility
by storm
this switch of focus soon paid off in
the summer of 1879 gold won the
inaugural irish lawn tennis championship
before heading across the sea to england
and the wimbledon championship
gold was on form and only dropped two
sets on his way to the final he had a
notoriously strong backhand and an
all-round attacking approach to the game
often charging the net to finish a point
off instead of playing shots from the
baseline like most of his peers
the final were to take place on a monday
and the two finalists could not have
taken more different approaches to their
preparations
reverend hardly delivered sermons to his
flock whilst gold spent the sabbath
preoccupied with spirits of a very
different kind
when the time came to clash rackets
gold had a brutal hangover he lost in
straight sets
the defeat hit gold pretty hard
dejected and clearly not one to learn
from his mistakes he turned back to the
drink throwing opium into the mix for
good measure
what had once been a promising tennis
career
quickly began to unravel the following
year gold failed to defend his irish
championship and in 1883 he retired from
the game for good moving to london to
focus on his new passions
getting utterly off his face and
gambling all of his money away
despite the fact gold appeared to have
his finger firmly on the self-destruct
button he somehow managed to find
himself a wife during his time in london
a twice widowed french woman by the name
of mary jordan
she owned a local dressmaker and whilst
it's rumored she was no oil painting she
could be charming when she wanted to be
though it seems that was mostly when she
was asking one of her well-heeled
clients to lend her some cash jarodn had
expensive tastes and the income from her
business wasn't enough to satisfy them
the pair were married in 1891 and they
soon set about running up various debts
all over london
so much so that they found themselves
unable to pay the rent on their large
expensively furnished house in the west
end
ever the responsible couple gold and his
new bride resolved this little problem
by selling all of the landlords
furniture and making a run for it
their destination was canada where the
golds used their stolen cash alongside
some fresh loans to open a new
dressmaking shop in montreal
the business was actually pretty
successful but no matter how much money
they made
the couple had no trouble whatsoever
spending it on their many vices and
regular trips back to europe
by this time they were passing
themselves off as sir and lady gold
an image i can only assume was slightly
undermined when they opened a laundry
business after moving back to england in
but the golds were never going to be
satisfied with a life of cleaning other
people's skid marks and soon enough they
began to plot a new way to make some
fast cash
by scamming europe's growing number of
casinos
mrs gold sorry lady gold believed she'd
come up with a foolproof system for
beating the house and her husband was
busy working on a method to break
roulette using a wheel he'd installed at
his home they chose monte carlo as the
location to try out their schemes its
glittering casino attracted royalty and
the well-to-do from all over europe but
also the continent's worst swindlers and
hustlers so the goals fitted right in
nevertheless they attempted to assume an
air of respectability by taking along
lady gold's young niece isabel giroud
like many who came before them and no
doubt many who came afterwards their
attempts to cheat at the tables were
well let's just say no dice
so they found themselves in a familiar
position unable to pay off their costs
and in need of a cash injection
at that point the dastardly duo came
across a wealthy swedish widow emma
luvon who fond of wearing opulent
jewelry presented the perfect mark she
loans the couple a thousand francs more
than 5 000 pounds in today's money which
was quite a thing to do for total
strangers
of course the cash disappeared almost
instantly and when luvon visited the
gold's hotel to demand repayment
she mysteriously disappeared too
when lyvonne failed to show up at her
hotel by midnight one of her travelling
companions raised the alarm and when the
police pitched up at the gold's hotel
they found the couple had left for
marseille leaving behind miss shiradon
who explained that her aunt had gone to
see a doctor
it wasn't exactly a cast-iron excuse and
it started to look flimsier still when
the police had a little poke around the
gold's hotel room
where they found a saw a hammer and
rather a lot of blood
you don't need to be sherlock holmes to
figure out what must have happened to
poor madame levon
two days later the golds arrived in
marseille where loaded down with luggage
they asked for help from a station
porter the man noticed a foul smell
coming from one of the cases as well as
oozing blood
gold claimed he was transporting
slaughtered poultry i mean he doesn't
carry around chicken carcasses in their
luggage but sadly for the golds the
porter was not in fact a complete [__]
and he promptly requested that they
accompany him to the police station they
tried in vain to bribe the man but
instead he raised the alarm the police
showed up not long afterwards and when
they came to open their oozing stinking
case
they made a grim discovery it contained
the torso of the late madame levon
sans her in its another suitcase
contained a pair of legs and a head and
surprise surprise marie gold's handbag
was full of luvon's jewelry the gold
tried to make an athletic sidestep
around the truth by claiming a spurned
lover had burst into their hotel room
and killed lyvonne taking that story
further they said they'd been worried
that informing the police would have led
to them being blamed for the murder so
they'd done the only reasonable thing
cut up a human body before hightailing
it out of monte carlo obviously
the gruesome murder and resulting
prosecution created a huge stir in the
media by the time the gold came to trial
their story had changed yet again
mr gold confessed he'd acted alone first
bludgeoning glyvon with a pestle as she
was slipping some cherry liqueur before
stabbing her repeatedly as she fought
for her life
during the course of proceedings however
the court decided that it was in fact
mrs gold who was the instigator of this
most horrific of killings there was even
the suggestion that her first two
husbands
may have received a helping hand in
departing the world of the living
mr gold was given life in prison and mrs
gold was sentenced to death by
guillotine at this point historical
accounts diverge one story suggests the
guillotine couldn't be found to carry
out the execution whilst in another
authorities in monaco decided to commute
mrs gold's sentence to life in prison
after she demanded to be executed in
front of the casino
which wouldn't exactly have been good
for business
regardless she only managed seven years
of her sentence before dying of typhoid
in french prison in 1914
mr gold was to serve out his life
sentence on the aptly named devil's
island this was one of the salvation
islands in french guyana
though by all accounts there wasn't a
hell of a lot of salvation going around
the disease-infested place was pretty
much hell on earth
with many convicts dying from tropical
illnesses like malaria if the diseases
didn't get you sooner or later something
else would the death rate amongst
prisoners was a staggering 75 percent
but in the end it wasn't disease or
guard brutality that did it for gold
separated from the woman he loved he
committed suicide less than a year into
his sentence
so then
a dark end to a villainous tale
and a reminder of an important lesson
no matter where life takes you always
choose your doubles partner wisely
thanks for watching